hey guys so it's five to seven Thursday
so we'll do these videos on Tuesdays and
Thursdays this one's gonna be another
easy 15 minutes so similar exercise to
the second one we had a few different
points but we're gonna do the same thing
so we're gonna do fifteen minute warm-up
15-minute calisthenic fifteen minute
I'm sorry five minute warm-up
five-minute calisthenic five minute
meditation all right let's get started
so same as last one we're going to warm
up with this I'm going to do goose of
this weight force the idea is to get
used to making horseman lower body
letting that force
translate up the upper body it's nice to
warm up with because the legs are big
someone start working those muscles a
little bit
keep the rest of the body relaxed
you can afford back with this yeah I get
here the end relax the upper body but
the local I do work I'm just kind of a
little long so they're making forces in
a slightly different way this way
forward back
I
slightly different in you seen a lot of
Ike your schools if it's on this is the
way that's happening in the body up and
back down
arms out and behind the back
forward and down you back up one side
and that hello
Oh
on the knee let me talk about on
Tuesdays class don't really this joint
answer going back for
and in middle school fee
back to the parts
if you got in front so I'm going to
reach for my hands for a little bit
until I start to feel that pinch so or
the stretching back my leg don't Brown
this fine so don't do this right so if
you do that it's easy to get to your
toes but keep a nice straight spine you
do this and walk forward until you feel
that notice I'm keeping my clothes back
now once you're relaxing spa and relax
your toes
good eat in the stomach hands are done
beat the shoulders here big breath in
reaching through the crown of the head
the stretch should be in your stomach
right you should be feeling it all
across your four finger in the front and
not the back so you're not pinching your
spine rounding that spine out good total
of the ground pushing the Dinos straight
back so my heels not touching my legs
straight and pushing up with my hands
here
drop the knees back
okay so sitting here deliberating one
foot through like this position here so
this foot Street decide I'm going to
balance on my buck watch switch my feet
in front bring them across here go to
the other side back and forth now if you
need to put your hands on the graphic
your hands we ground right so you're off
balance but you got but ideally you want
to keep your core in the center as you
rotate around
yeah hey so that was my heat moving that
I'll do my button when we're gonna keep
in place and with my knees across to the
other side as you do this try not to let
your feet move up right so I mean don't
let your feet slide out like this leave
your feet in place and move around your
feet
you know put your hands into that
convenience a little trying keep your
hands off the net
good next we're gonna sit up switch our
feet behind my feet are switching behind
it
sit up such feet
yeah all right on your back put our feet
up in here and circle feet back and
forth see some eight meters like uh like
an eight give your keys to mix up eight
other direction
bicycle turn extend out as far as you
can so try not to make it here nice long
strokes other direction
good flutter kick too late straight
you hope you like that just up the
ground good just sit up
hold position my feet are still off the
ground and down up down up down up down
up
hold the position
and yeah bring it up crunchy
good job onto the side drop your leg
side to side so keep my shoulders on the
mat my arms on the back legs from side
to side
we're kept I'm good bring your feet up
and what's that thank you
yeah okay on to our meditation
okay so we're gonna do observational
meditation again which remember the idea
that observational meditation is just to
stay present so had my conscious my mind
conscious mind my unconscious mind can
do all kinds of amazing stuff when
conscious mind has mainly one job which
is kick out ideas and analyze idea to
kick out analyze kick out analyze so
what I want to do is let that part of me
not get attached to anything right so I
don't want to have thought about
something so I don't want to think you
know it's warm in here or whatever
whatever the thought process is which is
I just want to let it go and be present
right so be in the moment
whatever's now but don't attach to it
don't add extra stuff to it don't think
a lot of extra stuff okay
three strikes on the bell in on three
strikes the bail out the timer set it'll
go off before it we're done so wait for
the bell and that's what you're looking
for
sorry my tablet freaked out for a second
all right here we go
[Music]
okay guys we're still an easy track here
we'll start building as we go next time
we'll do so next week we'll do 20 minute
workouts I'm about the same intensity
level though and then the week after
that we'll bump up the intensity a
little so I get everybody ready to come
back to the dojo just a real quick thing
on meditation sis was coming up for me
while we were doing it right now so it's
hard to understand what you're trying to
do when you're meditating it's really
kind of hard when you first have no
concept of what it is you're supposed to
be doing your mind is going to attach to
stuff and what what I mean by you know
attaches like a thought comes up in my
head so like you know I hear the birds
outside and then I go oh there's birds
outside and then I think oh I wonder
what kind of bird that is and then oh
you know I think those are Blue Jays and
then oh I wonder if they're on the roof
or you know so so you see how my mind
starts following down following that
that thought that I had right now
ideally you're always going to do that
you're never going to stop going birds
right
you'll probably always say Birds or
whatever right ideally where you want to
get though is to where there is nothing
that goes with the birds right you know
there's birds but there's nothing that
goes with it right and so for example a
little better than the one example I
just gave less Birds oh I think they're
Blue Jays let that go right so like the
sooner you can let go of that thought
the better and then you'll get to a
smaller and smaller hotspot where
there's not really thoughts exactly to
go with it and like my thoughts I mean
an attachment to what that thought was
and and why this is a problem is because
it's not being in the moment right so so
what moments are these tiny little
fractions of time like these slivers
sliver slivers of time and so when that
moments here and gone it's here and gone
but we have a tendency to use our
conscious mind to to prolong those
moments right to to make them seem like
they're longer than they actually are
and it does a lot of weird stuff
that we could talk about that's kind of
esoteric and we won't get into it but
but basically it takes me out of the
moment because I'm prolonging one moment
that's already passed I'm missing the
new moments that are coming in and I
always want to be present for the new
moments that are coming in at least when
I'm doing that kind of meditation right
now I'm not saying it's how you live
your life right there's times when you
need to be analytical about things and
times when you need to be in a flow
state about things all kinds of
different ways but we're doing this
observational meditation the idea is to
let go of a thought as soon as possible
to detach from that thought as soon as
possible okay guys we will see you on
Tuesday around seven o'clock so you know
maybe a little earlier a little later
but I'll try and make it right about
7:00 I usually get antsy when the time
gets here in about five minutes telling
my god I need to start this and I always
think this is gonna take longer than it
does to get set up so all right we'll
see you guys next week take care